hi guys you're not going to want to miss
this episode with heather heing and
brett weinstein authors of a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century evolution and the challenges of
modern life we got into so much stuff on
this and thrilling almost two hour long
podcast including uh my questions to
them
my so-called existential questions a
thrilling three you want to miss that
please do
subscribe to my newsletter
briankating.com if you want to get those
and otherwise you'll hear fascinating
kind of motivation why do they write
this book why now are we as a culture
experiencing senescence this degradation
that is often spoken about often in the
context of telomeres which of course
brett made major contributions to
uh and uh this notion of are there
cultural or you know kind of epigenetic
telomeres as he corrected my
pronunciation we talked about their
so-called omega principle we talked
about the benefit of abstinence versus
indulgence hyper novelty how to raise
your kids
and of course i actually engaged in some
field work that you'll hear about
visiting the famous madagascar poisonous
frog
and lastly we concluded with kind of
some takeaways as to
both your audience questions which i
took on my youtube channel dr brian
keating if you're listening to this
and also questions as to what other
civilizations maybe not even earthbound
maybe even alien civilizations what
would they be like
and many other topics why experiments
are good and bad and uh and the kind of
notion that the internet is becoming
what the campfire used to provide in
ancient history so i hope you'll pick up
a copy hunter gatherer's guide i
listened to it it's read by the two of
them quite phenomenal and i know you're
gonna enjoy this episode with none other
than uh heather heing and dr brett
weinstein dr heather heing
into the impossible enjoy
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
today
we are welcoming
two guests we haven't had two guests on
the end of the impossible podcast very
frequently
i was discussing with my wife you know
how she'd like to work with me or i with
her and she said there were certain you
know the waterfall she would like to
jump off of before she would consider
working with me but today it's heather
heing and brett weinstein joining us all
the way from the from the northwest i
believe right guys that is correct we're
in portland oregon you guys are the
proprietors of the dark horse podcast
and this is the second weinstein i've
had on the podca actually you're the
third i've had a zev in the background
as well uh he's doing some work with me
here at uc san diego but um i'm grateful
to your brother eric for helping to
facilitate this and i am grateful to you
guys for agreeing to match the length of
time that he has spent on my podcast in
the next 26 hours so everybody sit back
and enjoy
uh so it's a pleasure to have that's
with p breaks is that is that right no
bio breaks will be provided damn uh
so you guys have written a wonderful
really fascinating new book called the
hunter gatherers guide to the 21st
century subtitle evolution and the
challenges of modern life
guys the first thing i do with all my
guests is what you're never supposed to
do which is to judge a book by its cover
but rather than read your theses which i
did do and i will get to that in a
minute uh this is the first book that
many of my uh my audience members will
be familiar with or have a chance to
encounter so what else can they judge it
based on so guys
where did the title come from um and
where did uh and where did the cover art
image come from is that the two of you
guys gathering hunting on the cover
making making yeah there we go thank you
there it is uh is that us brett i i wish
i could claim it was us i wish as a
fallback i could claim it was actually
our most recent common ancestor but
given the populations that you and i
come from i don't think that's plausible
either that person was an
agriculturalist
yeah so that's that's presumably true
but um yeah actually the design before
we talk about the name of the book the
design of the cover was actually one
that brett and i had in our head and we
actually mocked it up and sent it to the
excellent artists at our wonderful
publisher and this is this is what
resulted so um you know we're very
pleased with that but but the title a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century is of course a reference as
brechus said to
the ancestors that we had and the
paleolithic on the african savannah
which is what so many people have in
their heads when they think of human
ancestry human pre-history you know what
it was that we used to be doing and you
know people even imagine that it's that
it's the thing to which we must refer if
we are to live our our most adapted
lives and really one of the premises of
the book is we don't have just a
singular singular environment of
evolutionary adaptiveness we have many
environments of evolutionary
adaptedness and so sure we are adapted
to the african savannas of the
paleolithic and the coast the african
coast but also more recently to being
agriculturalists as brett said
almost all modern humans are the
descendants of agriculturalists for 10
to 12 000 years and we're also
pre-industrialists and you go farther
back the opposite direction in time from
that cover and we're all primates we're
all mammals we're all fish we're all
animals and you know we we bear the mark
of all of those moments of our
evolutionary history
there's also a little wink in there uh
to the hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
because of course there's a little
analogy here right our the argument in
the book the most central one is that we
in the 21st century despite this
environment effectively having been of
our own making are somewhat out of our
depth like an earthling traveling the
cosmos so
uh that's where it comes from i think
maybe we conclude that actually a towel
is not going to be sufficient
useful yeah yeah unlike unlike in
douglas adams right uh hitchhiker's
guide and there's plenty of fish and the
the the answer to all of life's
questions is also revealed in here with
many many tips from you guys and i want
to get into that especially parenting
tips but before we do
uh yesterday heather in your honor i
took my clan uh to the world famous san
diego zoo
and i wanted to do some field work to
kind of channel my inner heather hein
before the interview that i knew we'd
conduct today and so i captured an image
at great danger to myself and my
membership i captured an image of of
this little guy i'm wondering if you can
recognize who that is heather
gosh i i i think that must be an
amphibian i can barely see is it
possible it's a it's a newt or is it a
frog wait it's a frog right yeah
it's hard to see any chance you can't
show us one more time kind of look like
a tomato frog is that
well it's red
it might yeah boy
yeah it could be a tomato if i
discovered it from an island smaller
from an island
it's probably madagascar
very good i was hoping to trip you up
heather but i couldn't trip you up it is
a tree frog it is from madagascar but
its name is
as brett said the sambhava tomato frog
that's hopeless yeah are you very good
amazing you guys you haven't lost a bit
since graduate school whereas i have
lost everything uh except for my hair
that's all i get to keep actually we've
seen that frog in person yeah i'm sure
it's poisonous so i'm sure heather
you've done battles with with even worse
uh with worse entities than this little
plum fellow um he doesn't look dangerous
but looks can be deceiving right um so i
want to ask you first heather what is so
fascinating about frogs that could make
you know we do our dissertations here
about you know grand unified theories
and and about uh new cosmological models
predating the existence of the big bang
when space time didn't even exist what
about a frog could possibly envelop a
person in an entire phd and perhaps
their career as it did with you at least
early on that's a that's actually a
terrific question i mean i was i was
interested in the beginning in
uh the evolution of sociality evolution
of territoriality of parental care
sexual selection of sex roles and sexual
behaviors and you know one thing i used
to say when i was a professor to my
students is you can be
question driven or organism driven as an
organismal biologist and many people are
just driven to like i really want to
work on wolves i really want to work on
whales and frankly if you're driven by
the organism you are probably going to
be asking less deep questions overall so
i was driven by the the questions that i
was interested in and i started working
on primates and as it happened the very
first field season that i was working
which was in central america i had a
hypothesis about what particular fruits
the local monkeys would be choosing
and i they were just m.i.a the monkeys
were missing in action could not find
them and what i did find instead was
sort of a natural experiment playing out
in front of me with regard to in in
central america was the dark poison
frogs which turn out to have no
relationship to the poison frogs of
madagascar but that sent me to
asking well there's an entire island
nation larger than the state of
california which has been closed to all
vasa all foreigners for at that point
many decades just opened up
no one knows anything about what's going
on there with regard to the behavior of
any of the organisms except the lemurs
anything i find will be new and i know
what i'm interested in again you know
social systems and sexual behavior and
territoriality let's go so yeah the
frogs are fascinating but it was really
more about uh studying questions that i
had a pre-existing interest in and
that's how you know that's also how we
end up landing at studying humans as
reflected in this book
so they're sort of a model in an
interesting way the way that you know
but you biologists use by the way i am
not known for my biological uh you know
competency or my evolutionary i always
say in high school when i had to dissect
the frog the frog always lived i mean i
was not good at this at this at this job
um well then you may not realize the
most interesting thing about frogs is
that they are self-assembling
ah
tell me more tell me more how does a
frog sell what does sample assembly mean
self-assembly means it it requires that
you do this within a species but uh one
egg
and one sperm when they come together
causes a frog it just all happens no one
has to put it together there's no
instructions it just
emerges from that beginning ah
interesting so you know i've been called
a self-made man who worships his creator
so i'll be sure to use that uh as an
example um in the book uh brett you and
the chapters so i have the book in
physical and digital and in audio form
and i recommend everybody buy at least
three copies so it can continue to climb
from number four on the new york times
bestseller list to number one uh as it
deserves and i want to ask you guys at
least until my next book comes out but
uh
i don't think it'll appear up there but
i want to ask you brett in the chat one
of the chapters that you read sort of
towards the end you talk about
experiments and and in the book you
might make the case that as as actually
the new york times posits you know and
they're kind of mini blurb you know the
evolutionary biologists uh posit that
the modern world is out of sync with our
ancient brains and bodies first of all
do you agree with that little snippet or
i thought it was a little bit
more nuanced than that bro what do you
make of that yeah
let's put it this way there's certainly
an important uh more than a grain of
truth in that but the the real lesson
the much harder one what we argue in the
book is that because the modern world is
so different from all of the
environments in which we adapted the map
of what we are and how it fits the world
is arbitrary there are some ways in
which it just happens to
remain a good fit and many ways in which
it's a terrible fit and one has to look
on a trait by trait basis to even figure
out
where we have to alter something in
order to again be at home in our own
world
and in the book there is sort of an
ominous looming you know kind of thought
that is
we're you know we're doing all these
experiments because as we get farther
and farther away not necessarily as you
guys argue you don't argue in favor as i
was surprised you don't argue in favor
of the say the paleo diet and the keto
diet so i went down to dunkin donuts and
i want to thank you guys for that uh
because you know
i had only lost five pounds as i said i
dropped five pounds from my chin to my
to my backside but i want to ask you
guys if you have this notion that kind
of reoccurs that we're doing all these
experiments we're experimenting with our
kids heather you talk about screens and
and all you know the availability of
pornography which we're not going to get
into and and all sorts of you know
gender selection we're not going to get
into that either
but that's not not my interest but the
notion of an experiment i think is it
shouldn't get a bad name and that's not
because i'm an experimental
astrophysicist i think it's experiment
is pure play it's pure
curiosity and i think curiosity is
probably one of the most undervalued
traits what do you guys say about this
categorization of we're doing an
experiment on our kids what's wrong with
experiments
well
the problem is that we have two meanings
for the word experiment one of them
means hey this is novel let's see how it
goes and the other is we'll make a
change and we'll see what the
consequence is
and so when
you say there's nothing wrong with an
experiment there's a question about
what's at stake right you know if you're
going to put an egg in the microwave the
worst thing that's going to happen is
you're going to have some cleanup to do
right so you can afford to run that
experiment and not be
overly diligent about figuring out how
you're going to collect the evidence but
when we're running experiments on
ourselves and even worse when we're
running experiments on our children and
future generations it is incumbent on us
to figure out what it is that we are
introducing to their environment and
what its consequence is likely to have
been so that if it's not a good thing we
can reverse it and we are not doing that
we are changing so many things at once
and paying very little attention to the
causality of the pathologies that in
effect we just keep treating symptoms
and adding more pathologies to them yeah
i agree with this i would say you know
the book is certainly not a call to
regression or traditionalism or you know
a past really imagined
uh history that we could return to even
if we thought we should and we when we
don't we don't we think neither that we
can nor that we should want to um but it
is a caution against
simply moving forward with all possible
paths because rather in favor of i would
say a scientific approach to experiment
in which we say here's the hypothesis
what are all the possible uh
predictions that follow from the
hypothesis and how would we know what
the outcome would be as opposed to sort
of a
free market driven in places where there
should be more regulation approach to
uh approach to you know human everything
and there is very little understanding
too often of you know what childhood is
what our brains are what it is that
we're actually losing when we open up
some of the boxes that we're opening up
and hopefully not finding pandora
written all over it exactly again at the
zoo yesterday either as i was
researching uh your beloved uh
amphibians and whatever they are um
things that i could dissect and still
live uh this um this thing came to my
mind that my kids
uh after seeing these exotic creatures
from galapagos turtle tortoises uh to
you know the most magnificent giraffes
were leaving and they spent more time
obsessing you know just paroxysms of joy
over the american red squirrel and
there's a squirrel in the parking lot
and i'm like great you know did can
maybe go check out that pigeon over
there guys you know you could have saved
me 500 bucks um
i wonder what is it about hyper novelty
that competes with kind of you know
mundanity
in a sense that why are we wired for why
would we have reason to think that we're
more wired for novelty rather than for
familiarity i guess that's my my
question heather yeah well you know it's
you're absolutely right and one of the
things that we find when we travel
before we get into deep nature that may
be the goal of where we're going is that
in the cities where we are we're sitting
around looking at say the grackles uh
which are of no interest to the local
people but they don't happen to be where
we are and we actually uh you know we
would be more like your children perhaps
and be watching the squirrels uh because
because they are fascinating and
certainly there are some there are some
domesticates or uh i guess just
associates of humans that have become so
common even um even for us that we don't
spend a lot of time noticing them but uh
it is it is absolutely true that
familiarity need not breed contempt but
it does create a kind of a background
level of i know that's there i'm not
going to pay any attention to it anymore
and so i mean this is
this is akin to our unending search for
growth which is not unique to humans but
of course because we have become so
so dominant on the planet it is the
thing that is likely to be our end and
so you know we argue in the book for
for a way to do an end run around growth
that actually uses resources and seeking
novelty that actually requires totally
new things
so
those organisms that have sought novelty
and have been risk takers
have been
often the ones that didn't make it back
but when they did make it when they were
successful they were the ones who
founded new lineages
so you know of course there is a
long-standing you know as old as 3.5
billion years on earth a long-standing
interest in exploration
of which novelty is a manifestation
and brett novelty as you guys talk about
a little bit is you know concomitant in
some level with risk or with exploration
to learn something new and requires
discovery to increase you know entropy
is natural to decrease it is is more uh
energetically uh challenging um as i was
coming into to work today it's the first
days of school here at uc san diego i
saw uh some some young people
skateboarding as is the most popular
mode of transportation outside of
surfboarding and they weren't wearing
helmets and they were uh instagramming i
could tell
and but they were wearing masks and i
found it very interesting this this you
know incredible and we're not going to
talk about covet obviously but but i
want to ask you guys uh but maybe brett
first but what what is this notion of of
human beings are we good at assessing
risks and are we good at predictive
um you know behavior to predict those
types of novel things as you guys so
cogently argue for that'll be beneficial
to us and not actually detrimental in
any way to us and we tend to
underemphasize these true risks of not
wearing a helmet on a skateboard while
you're instagramming
well i would argue
that in an ancestral environment in
which the population had been in the
same place doing the same thing for
generations we would be absolutely
excellent at assessing risk and in fact
assessing probably isn't even the right
word you would intuit risk you know the
way one does while driving you can be
having a conversation that's occupying
your conscious mind but some part of you
is paying attention to everything out
there and at the point that something
you know a truck swerves in front of you
suddenly it captures your attention but
you know exactly in that circumstance
because you do have a long history of
driving and you've seen a certain amount
you know what to think but
for
a modern person what should you think
about
the safety of ingesting
a
fruit from the supermarket that has been
grown with uh
molecules that we have no evolutionary
history with that you don't even know
about that's not labeled on the apple
anywhere what it was grown with so how
do you assess the risk of that and how
do you know whether your model is any
good
right if there's some danger for example
that you might come down with
parkinson's if you spend years eating
fruits and vegetables that have been
grown with these novel compounds at what
point do you reassess your model and say
hey i probably got that one wrong and
how do you know that it was the fruits
and vegetables rather than that new car
smell from the vehicle you purchased or
you know the way your carpet's off
gassed or right we've got again this
goes back to the question of experiments
we're running so many experiments at
once and not being systematic about
collecting the evidence that we really
have a very poor sense and
i'll say one more thing which is
we notice very frequently that our
civilization
has an absolute obsession
with protecting you from provable risks
in the short term and it is
absolutely indifferent to exposing you
to
likely risks in the long term that are
outside of the bounds of provability and
this has a lot to do likely with the
fact that the way the system gets good
at this is through litigiousness
and so anything that can't be proven is
effectively treated as if it doesn't
exist even if we can infer that it most
certainly must
which creates perverse incentives for
risk to not be provable
[Music]
very good uh the figure of gk chesterton
figures large in this book and many of
my listeners will be familiar with this
quote that uh does not appear in hunter
gatherers guide
when a man stops believing in god
he doesn't then believe in nothing he
believes in anything
heather how do you react to that
you guys are not proponents of any
particular religion although i i was
delighted to learn you do celebrate
hanukkah in your own special way at the
very end um but uh what does that mean
to you what is chesterton you know can
we selectively uh apply chestertonians
uh quips when when uh when it suits our
fancy and as in the case of the fence or
what do you make of this the uh believe
in nothing if uh doesn't believe in
nothing he believes in everything is god
some sort of connective tissue and of
what purpose does evolutionary speaking
does god serve
well that's that's a fascinating quote
and it's not one i've heard so let me
take first uh the the question about
whether or not we can selectively choose
the thinking of of a person and not
embrace their entire milieu and i would
say of course we can right
so let me just take a step aside from
your question for a moment and say
specifically the contribution of
chesterton that we introduce in the book
and or introduce within the confines of
the book not to the world but
is is chesterton's fence the idea that
if you see a fence and you don't know
what its purpose is you should not be
allowed nor courage to get rid of it
until then unless you can demonstrate
that you know what is what its function
was supposed to be
and presumably also demonstrate that it
no longer has that function or it is in
fact causing more harm than good and so
we then apply that more broadly and say
we can we see chesterton's fences all
over the modern world in the form of
chesterton's breast milk chesterton's
play and chesterton's religions so to
get to get to your point here you know
what what role does religion have in the
modern world well the idea that it is uh
that we're done with it that it was a
male adaptation that it was a dangerous
or a mind virus
cannot hold up to evolutionary scrutiny
right every every society that we know
of has some form of religion in which
the people in it the the majority of
people in it until the very modern times
in which we are living in you know
multivariate societies multi
multi-religious societies has has belief
and it helps organize
morality frankly
and
the idea that it is somehow additional
to
cheesecake for
humans is uh just it doesn't fit and i
wonder i suspect that brett has more to
say on this perhaps yeah
i think the problem you know we we do
talk about chesterton's fence
specifically in the in the context of
religion but
you know we have these two concepts that
we discussed there's the precautionary
principle and there's chesterton's fence
and they're really mirror images of each
other one is about the hazard of adding
novel things to a system and the other
is about taking away
uh things that have been long-standing
and
again this goes back to the
arbitrariness of the place we find
ourselves in history because we have
these traditions the traditions are
clearly not up to the challenge of
navigating modern hazards you know the
bible has
precious little to say about social
media and the hazards of algorithms to
our collective sense making well i would
actually push back on that right because
there are traits i mean you may know
from your upbringing there's a sense of
there's a notion of what's called lashon
hara the evil speech in judaism at least
which is the notion that um gossip is
not something that's false in other
words it's you're forbidden to lie in
general so it's you wouldn't be
forbidden again to tell something so
it's something that's true gossip is
true
and yet it spreads like wildfire more
than ever and the analogy that's used
typically uh in in the talmud is as one
of uh you know a man you know besmirches
the reputation of his rabbi and says oh
he's been married and divorced or
whatever and that's not you know
socially a great thing for this
particular man and the parishioner then
feels guilty and says how can i rectify
what i did to you rabbi and the rabbi
says simple just go get a feather pillow
and the guy goes okay i'll go get a
feather pillow that's it that seems
simple robert says no no cut it open my
gosh all right cut it i'll cut open the
pillow and
he goes and shake it out check it out
and the guy says all right i'll do it am
i forgiven and goes no now go out and
collect all the feathers the notion
being that you know the ability to
produce bs and and actually truth uh far
outstrips the ability to do it but the
notion of guarding your tongue the
actual quote in the in the torah and the
old testament the bible is you know you
should guard your tongue it's protecting
your life to choose life means to guard
your tongue against this true but
defamatory in some sense speech so i
wouldn't say that the bible doesn't
speak about it but with respect uh i i
would say that it it has many aphorisms
uh and the question is yeah which ones
you know to take seriously i know that
that's a harder problem right well
no i think you've picked a great example
because there's certainly a relevance if
gossip is bad then
the internet is an amplifier of that
badness it doesn't make it better it
makes it worse on the other hand there's
a whole lot that isn't covered there
right like what happens when it isn't
people deciding to say or not say but
it's algorithms decide designed to
increase somebody's bottom line that
result in people being fed things that
flatter their preconceptions and having
things hidden that would cause them to
challenge those preconceptions that
isn't mentioned and i'm not saying you
couldn't find some analog for that in
there but the basic point is come on
these texts were built by evolution they
were built by evolution with reference
to environments we don't live in some of
what they've got contained in them is
still as relevant as ever some of it is
upside down and backwards and much is
simply not covered so when you're left
with that kind of an arbitrary map the
question is what do you do and you know
the the atheists and the way that that's
been formulated in in recent times don't
have it right
right chesterton's quote is relevant
there the religious people who say hey
this stuff is still you know the word of
god and we have to take it uh as handed
to us
don't have solutions to some of the
problems we face and so you know heather
and i are not
happy about the message that we actually
have to confront the process of building
new traditions that are up to the
challenge of
regulating the way we interact with each
other and the world because we are bound
to get many things wrong in at least our
first and second attempts
um but
what choice do we have we live in a
world for which no one knows the best
rules
yeah
and it's kind of that that you know
emerging from the cave that i find so
you know
instructive illustrative um but again
just to not belabor the the religious
point i mean a lot of what you talk
about in this book both of you guys are
are really making the case in some way
not for religious or you know uh
political conservatism you know for sure
but but really for um take extracting
the good thing you talk a lot about
community about the campfire that's a
strong metaphor we're gonna get into
that and how in modern times the
internet is becoming a perverse campfire
in some sense but but religion is
community small groups hundreds of
people go to synagogues not millions of
people or temples or churches or
buddhist shrines you guys mentioned
buddhism in the book as well
as a positive example of a prudential
religion that has adaptivity built
within it so i guess the the gathering
and hunting within the religious
structure they would seem that religious
life offers a lot of what you know the
lacunae that
your book is designed to fill in some
sense um in terms of you know parenting
i mean you basically talk about you know
discipline but also love and and and um
you know kind of having those two hands
everything being this double-edged sword
that the bible speaks about so i mean
why not just shortcut it why why should
you know why should we listen to you two
brilliant you know scientists we can say
this tradition has been tested for
thousands of years you know a b tested
group tested you know why not just pick
a religion happen maybe choose the
religion you were born into and and
stick with it even if you don't believe
it i mean i had freeman dyson on my
first guest
a he called himself basically what i do
you know in some sense a practicing uh
agnostic so why not just you know pick a
system it's been group tested long time
and uh instead of trying to you know
kind of make the rules up as we go go
along now what do you guys think about
that i would say that's a great start
and it gets you a long way in a lot of
regards but it doesn't necessarily tell
you
what to eat and uh whether or not to let
the led lights flash in your bedroom at
night and uh what to adopt of uh what
modern authorities are telling you about
how you should form your relationships
you know when it's possible that if what
you're trying to do is simply
wear your book you the religion that
you've picked has an opinion if you go
with that
you are more likely to be right than if
you had nothing to guide you at all um
but having a book that is as you say a b
tested you know time tested all of this
with an evolutionary understanding of
what we are and what we've been because
what we are is far more tested than any
book that humans have created you know
because we are not just hunter-gatherers
we are also monkeys and primates and
mammals and fish
we are all of these things and you make
the case heather i think in the section
that you read um that i loved you know
you really make the case for abstinence
i don't mean like puritanical it's just
you should you should practice fasting
in a certain sense and and many
religions do that uh to very good effect
refraining from you know pornography
from things that didn't exist in the
pre-evolutionary past and i i just want
to thank you for that because i do think
there's a benefit to it you know we just
had yom kippur in our religion and you
know my kids fasted from you know from
dinner to breakfast or whatever and
but but they recognize that it's good
and that they wanted to do it but they
couldn't do it and i think like all the
more so in judaism we don't use screens
we don't you know communicate on the
sabbath and things like that you also
advocate for that kind of the digital
detox you talk about taking trips for
weeks with your children that i don't
know if they were what age they were at
but you know you turn on the phone and
all of a sudden you get riddled with
with email and that suggests to me you
guys do take sabbaths too thought maybe
talk about the importance of that in
terms of recharging the human uh you
know what what the human needs either
one of you is wait i want to go back and
and push back on something you said
earlier because it really gets to the
heart of the matter here right why not
just accept some time-tested religion
and go with that right
but how did it get that way and the
implication is partially uh carried in
your argument for a b testing the fact
is
secular
sectarian disagreements are the fodder
by which selection refines belief
systems to make the time-tested versions
that we have but the other part of that
which we argue for in our book
is that there is a mechanism for radical
upgrade as well
and you're right there's you know people
will struggle if you're a conservative
and you look into our book you will see
conservatism if you're a radical and you
look into our book you will find
radicalism what the hell is that do we
not know what we're doing no the
argument is actually that there is a
tension between these things and that
when you are faced with circumstances
for which you don't have the answers
they're not contained in whatever book
it is that you inherited from your your
your your
your ancestors you have to have a
mechanism for figuring out what the next
book is going to say and it doesn't
involve sitting down to write the next
book right it involves people around a
campfire proposing things to each other
and figuring out what the foothill might
look like and then that foothill is
ascended by disagreements and you know
you might have two populations
do you follow the shoe do you follow the
gourd you know that sort of thing and
those
groups that have or those lineages that
have a belief system that more
surgically suggests behaviors that are
adaptive will out-compete groups that
have messier versions of these things so
in any case i think the point is do you
want to subscribe to the book you've
been handed or do you want to subscribe
to the process that created those books
in the first place and what our book
argues is that that process is an
evolutionary process and we know where
we are in that right we're at a point
where where
a radical transition is necessary if
we're to survive
so if if i may speak to the question of
sabbath which
strikes me as having at least two very
important aspects
one is that it allows you to remember
who you are and who you are with and to
be focused on the people both yourself
your inner world and the people you are
with
and uh of of course we need more of that
in modern in modern life and this is
fundamental to what humans are but the
other aspect of sabbath which you refer
to and yom kippur of course
also does this is is uh
that it
it reveals the benefit of privation
and um too much of modern life is about
seems to be about maximizing comfort and
making sure that we are never in any way
outside of the bounds which we had
imagined we would be outside of and we
argue at least implicitly throughout the
book although i'm not sure we ever
explicitly say this that actually
pushing up against the bounds of what
both you think is possible for your own
body and brain and emotions and what is
actually possible is actually itself
health enhancing and restoring and so
for instance uh you know obviously we
should be moving our bodies some every
day you know we should all be walking
some amount of time every day but that's
not sufficient we also should be
absolutely pushing our bodies to the
limit sometimes so that our bodies know
what it is to be pushed and what kinds
of places we might need to push it and
that is going to be the thing that makes
us stronger and more anti-fragile and so
living a life within sort of narrow
confines or even fairly broad confines
where we never where we never even
approach those boundaries makes us
fragile yeah and i see that even in the
you know kind of uh ability to identify
with someone who's truly hungry i mean
i've never been truly hungry you guys
have probably because you've been on
such amazing adventures some of which
are documented in the wonderful book
that we're discussing a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century authors
dr heather heing and dr brett weinstein
and this uh this this book talks about
you know kind of the the just culturally
it's it's just it's it's a true wake-up
call but i came to think of it as an
interesting dichotomy and what brett was
just saying a couple minutes ago between
like what do you choose and how do you
know how to choose and i saw a
fundamental dichotomy between producers
and consumers so you guys are producers
and consumers but your producers your
youtube channel which is extremely
popular dark horse podcast you can find
everywhere podcasts are sold um and uh
and but you're also consumers you
consume voraciously um uh you know
scholarly and otherwise now i started to
think about uh the very first gripping
opening story about rain in the
mountains
and i started to think well it's great
that that your guide and well maybe you
guys can recap the story very briefly uh
how you almost weren't here to tell this
story and you almost didn't have the
children that you wonderfully uh are
blessed to have um maybe tell that story
and then i want to make the point that
there's a certain amount of credit that
goes to you guys for being consumers and
knowing i should trust this guy this
this guru uh because he is a producer of
this knowledge but there's an obligation
of the consumer as well and i wonder if
that's not harder to act to acquire um
then but maybe heather can you start off
with the story about rain in the
mountains and then brett can you comment
on the obligations of the consumer if he
or she wants to survive and thrive yeah
so it was our first season as graduate
students as would-be scientists in coast
in costa rica we had spent a summer
previously exploring
uh central america so we were not new to
these ecosystems or we didn't think we
were but we had both grown up you know
privileged kids in los angeles in the
weird world it wasn't called the weird
world then but um we were very much of
the first world as it was called then so
we were at this little tiny field
station in sarapaqui in northeastern
costa rica and we were done with our
field work for the day it was hot the
two of us chose to walk down to the
river where we would swim where we would
swim many days
to get there you have to cross a high
bridge a relatively high bridge and we
were about halfway across when a man we
did not know
a man we we took to be a local farmer
approached us our spanish was terrible
at this point he spoke no english and uh
he
basically got our attention and kept
saying
there was rain in the mountains today
and he would point to the mountains and
we were just getting hotter and harder
standing there wishing that we could
extract ourselves from this conversation
but feeling that we needed to you know
engage with him because he was trying to
engage with us but uh at some point he
pointed with increasing urgency to the
water and said look
and in the few seconds that we had been
looking away it had begun to rise
and
what he was telling us without you know
with the very few words that we shared
between us in a language that wasn't
ours although we were in his home and
you know in his in his home landscape uh
where the language that was spoken was
his was that rain in the mountains that
all of us are aware of that has to go
somewhere
and had he not stopped us what we we
stood on that bridge as that water rose
and rose and rose and very soon there
were trees coming down the river and the
bank on which we would have been
standing had disappeared under this
flash flood
this man saved our lives probably at
least one of ours and
we were
young proto-scientists in graduate
school you know working towards phds
doing tropical biology thinking that we
knew a place because we'd been there for
several weeks studying you know frogs
and bats but we didn't and so you know
the point is that it actually takes much
longer to truly know a place and all of
us feel like locals now
in whatever landscape we walk into but
in fact it takes a lot more experience
than most of us give credit for
and actually you can uh
you can see the very same thing in the
tragic videos that emerged from banda
aceh for example during the boxing day
tsunami where people many of them who
lived on the coast but whose ancestors
hadn't been there did not know what to
make of a sea that had radically receded
and revealed you know sea floor that
they had never seen before and many
people
walked out to look at the fish
yeah right and uh were killed because
they didn't know how
they didn't understand that that water
was going to have to come back
so anyway yes there is something to be
said about really knowing a place and
that's that's what saved us in the
instance of the the incident on the
bridge
so brett as a consumer what kinds of you
know obligation there might be
obligations on producers and they may
get benefits uh they may have increased
you know facility if they're perceived
as being the repository of wisdom of
local knowledge of life hacks as we call
them now but didn't call them back
thousands of years ago
but what obligations are there on the
consumer uh and what benefits accrue to
him or her for being astute in their
judgment of perception of which mountain
guides to listen to so to speak to
torture this analogy
well i'm a little uh unsure of what you
mean by consumer do you mean in the
economic sense something no just like
you're hearing the information but there
is you you were astute enough uh
something in you guys
listen to this guide or listen to this
farmer and that saved your life uh but
not everyone i would have you know i
would have been you know probably the
former brian keating i would have um hot
what are you talking about man let me
let me take a dive off this waterfall to
impress my girlfriend um but you didn't
do that so there's some there was
something in you guys that was astute
enough or perceptive enough and i'm kind
of asking i'm in hopes that it wasn't
based on something unique to your guys
intellect or you know something that we
normal people perhaps can cultivate to
be more perceptive consumers in that
sense of wisdom of of of past traditions
or or even of you know of these pretty
naturally gifted you know people in our
culture
yeah it's an excellent question um i'll
take a slight detour uh just yeah
something that accidentally
revealed something to me about this
which is uh i'm not a believer really in
dyslexia because reading and writing are
so
new that to say that you have a defect
with respect to them really doesn't make
any sense right this is some
thing modern humans have chosen to do
and some of us are less adept at
processing the symbols but
if dyslexia was a thing i'd have it in
spades
and it has an impact therefore on the
way i read it makes it
less fun more
uh
it's more exhausting for me i know than
people who read easily but it has a
positive upside which i think
non-dyslexics don't necessarily spot
which is because i know i can't trust
my
interpretation of the symbols on the
page
i'm constantly looking
to see whether or not what i'm reading
makes sense
right because the way i know that i've
misread something is that it doesn't
make sense and so then i know i have to
go back and reread it but lots of times
if you if you get good at this process
you're reading something doesn't make
sense you go back to find what symbol
you've misunderstood
and there's nothing you just know it
doesn't make sense and so i guess my
point is i'm not a big believer
i think you should really minimize the
consumer part of you that even what we
do that looks nominally like being a
consumer like reading shouldn't be a
passive activity it should be one in
which your
conscious mind is actively engaged in
evaluating what's coming in and the
profit comes
when you know if somebody's telling you
something and they're ostensibly an
expert in the topic but they say
something that doesn't match the model
that you have of the universe well
there's an opportunity there either
they're about to learn something or
you're about to learn something and that
you know i think deciding to be a
consumer as little as possible is
probably the best advice
that that we can give can i uh can i add
something to that actually um yes i
think
all of us
exist in some way outside of the
mainstream you know we are all
non-normies on some domain on some axis
and you know it may be dyslexia or color
blindness or left-handedness or
you know neurodiversity you know being
on the spectrum
or many many other other things and you
know it's become very fashionable now to
identify what way in which you are
request
this is not that this is a
how about take that as a hidden
superpower by which you can stand
outside of whatever the main the
mainstream narrative is
and use it as a way to interpret it in
such that uh or rather with tools that
maybe all the so-called normies don't
have right and this this actually allows
you to have insight and i think
really if you do it with integrity and
respect to um open up your arms to more
of humanity and to more of the the
wisdom and wealth of skills that that
humans bring and you know i've said
i've said before that uh the many years
that we spent teaching in college
classrooms at a yes public liberal arts
college but a non-elite one one that had
yes students from the tops of their
classes but also students who had been
completely destroyed by school and um
students who were the first in their
families to go to college and you know
and veterans and you know single mothers
you know all range of people
what that experience taught me in part
uh was that almost in a room full of 25
or 50 students
almost everyone has something to teach
every other person in that room and
that's not to say that i was pretending
that i wasn't the professor and wasn't
there to teach some particular things
that i had written into the curriculum
and that i wanted to get to
um but that part of what we were doing
there was
indeed to return to the earlier concept
you know was building community such
that we had trust for one another such
that we could over time reduce the
skepticism we had for one another and
thus engage more and more deeply ideas
that might have on the first day of
class seemed polarizing or extreme well
no now now that we have some trust and
you can recognize that if i say
something that you wildly disagree with
you know it's not because i'm a monster
maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm not wrong
maybe you don't have the information i
have maybe i don't have the information
you have but let's take the time to
explore yeah and i think that is of
course the purpose of
education the latin root is ejukari it
means to pour out of not to put into i
want to talk if you'll indulge me i
wanted to talk about this later but i
heather you just brought it up you guys
were uh famously
you know unemployed from evergreen state
university or um and
i think it's kind of a tragedy um when i
look back on it and i read your writings
and i know a little bit about each of
you just because we're you know friends
with uh brett's brother
but but the point of you guys as natural
educators as born educators as educators
defining who you are and i remember i
got my pilot's license in the 1990s and
on that day i remember my flight
instructor saying now your identity is
forever changed you will never not have
been a pilot you know and it becomes a
part of who you are even if i find
little tiny cessna you know that i can't
fit in anymore and uh and now
um but i can do that and i can go down
and rent a little plane but
you guys aren't professors anymore and
and yet it's it's sort of like your
claws or your or your uh web spinning
ability or your honey making it like
it's what you guys were born to do
clearly it is and i i won't tolerate if
you guys disagree with me because you
guys are human you know incarnations of
education machines i want to ask you how
is it dealing with the ability with the
fact that you're not teaching you're
teaching you're teaching at much bigger
scale your publications are read by way
more people that your h index will be
much higher but you're not at a
university how how does that make you
guys feel
um
it's an interesting question
let's put it this way it was a tragedy
but i don't think it was a personal
tragedy i think what happened to us was
a preview and we are all suffering this
tragedy
and i will say
um
heather and i i don't think have talked
about this explicitly maybe we have but
when
the i mean i prefer to think of us as uh
catapulted out of the academy is what
happened to us when that happened to us
we were asked as we were invited to
speak various places how shall we
introduce you right what are you now if
you're not a professor and we adopted
professors in exile as our
um as our i don't know what it would be
yeah
but the point was that was actually
uh yeah it was you know there was a wink
involved but it was also an accurate
representation it was a little bit like
your pilot example the point was well we
did that that's still who we are didn't
change the day we resigned our positions
and i think it still is and as you point
out we are now not in the same milieu we
are still
teaching in a new way we're figuring out
how to do it
and
uh i don't
i don't feel i feel a loss surrounding
something that actually
isn't so easy to do at most
colleges or universities we had
by virtue of the way teaching was done
at evergreen we taught one class
full-time students took one class
full-time and that class could go on for
a full year which resulted in a level of
understanding between teachers and
students that is unparalleled and
i missed that but were we to suddenly
have positions as professors somewhere
else that part wouldn't be restored
right it would be a dim shadow of that
and
what we have now is quite different but
uh it it has not eliminated
the
sense of meaning that accompanies every
day and the sense of meaning is closely
aligned to the one we had when we were
in the classroom i i agree with that and
i would say you know there are catch
phrases in
educational theory that people are
probably familiar with and that sound
ridiculous at this point things like
lifelong learner and theory to practice
right um and yet
you know both of those things be the
idea of being a lifelong learner is
actually
foundational and i you know my my father
has been has been dead for eight years
now but he was a computer scientist who
didn't view himself as an educator
but was a mentor to so many people and i
think in the same way we sort of became
accidental educators because what we
were
were children who were becoming adults
with a curiosity about in our case
largely you know the natural world and
the human world uh that didn't stop you
know any day
that uh you learned something new and
this was something that my father used
to say to me any day i learned something
new was a good day right and
it doesn't take very much from there to
then want to share
not just the thing that you learned but
how it is that you can open yourself up
to
a personality of learning
yeah and of course you guys make the
strong case that tools are more
important than facts you say that in the
book and i wonder you know one one uh
very old tradition in weird countries
and maybe heather can you define weird
really quickly please yeah just uh those
those people living in countries that
are western educated industrialized rich
democratic or at least aspire to be
democratic small d but um i wonder one
institution that's quite old and i'm
wondering and i'm curious if it is not a
chesterton's fence is the university
system which dates back in its current
incarnation of a guy or a gal i guess
lately uh with a piece of rock you know
scraping on another piece of rock you
know behind their bodies um in front of
you know these bewildered and bemused
young people uh that day dates back to
at least 1089 in the city of bologna in
northern italy and i wonder that's been
there a long time it hasn't changed uh
and yet
brett you just mentioned a few minutes
ago i might preview what happened to you
might be a preview could it happen to me
should it happen to me not not exactly
what happened but is academia a
chesterton's fence should we should we
not respect it it's been around for so
long why advocate to change it or what
are would you advocate to change about
it
uh yeah this is a tough one because
my sense is uh if the academy didn't
exist it would be necessary to invent it
and it doesn't exist so it is now
necessary to invent it
um
no it's it's become the malignant
version or you know i you know i realize
who i'm talking to but at some level the
the argument that i make is it's like
your cherished family dog having caught
rabies
right
you're vaccinated against that
yes
we are but but the basic point is look
at the point your family dog has caught
rabies it's time to
grow up and realize that's not exactly
your family dog right and the university
system is like this now i think that's
tragic and i think it's crazy
obviously most of the resources you need
to build a great academy exist in what
we currently call the academy but it's
not functioning that way and the worst
part about it
is that the population of people that
staff the academy have lost track of
what it is they're supposed to be doing
right they just don't do the work and
you're using that sense you locked
you're talking about the faculty largely
yeah it is the faculty i mean uh there's
also a lot to be said about the uh the
bloating of the administration and its
role in this but the point is the
university has begun to see itself or
beyond begun to be to see itself it sees
itself
as a business or it sees itself as a
dispenser of truth not a place in which
vigorous challenges are dealt with in a
responsible way so that we can discover
the truth and until it either returns to
its roots or gets replaced by something
that is capable of doing the job
civilization's in serious trouble
because you know this
this isn't the 14th century
right we have problems that are serious
and require very careful analysis and
you absolutely need at least a
scientific apparatus that is capable of
telling you what you need to know rather
than what you want to hear and in a
context where we have markets plugged
very directly into our research system
that's not what we get right we get some
product that interfaces with our
collective well-being arbitrarily at
best
more often than not it might be
predatory and you know that's just
that's that's a dire situation to find
ourselves in
you see things in commonality just to
push gently back with respect um you see
things that are sclerotic that don't
change you know healthcare you know
construction of low-income family
housing and education these can't be
exported at least in their you know an
exact incarnation that i'm sitting in
this university um are they not
anti-fragile are they not i mean what is
it what is the
been around for a thousand years almost
in and more or less his current state
and except back then they had a barbaric
tradition i don't know heather and brett
if you know this but they had a barbaric
tradition that the students could go on
strike and then the professor wouldn't
get paid and thank god they've abolished
um
but uh but is it not anti-fragile you
guys talk about this uh resiliency as a
model heather
are these universities that i'm a part
of at least currently so um so
entrenched and so part of culture
as it is
that they're effectively resilient to
further perturbations and change
well i think sclerotic can look
antifragile and it can persist in in
appearing to be effective for a long
time after it actually is so
um i you know we're already seeing some
of the smaller places fail around the
edges right uh the elite institutions
and the large state institutions
especially the r1s are likely to last
for longer and um you know maybe maybe
they can reform
the places that were once
exactly where undergraduates at least
were most likely to get a really
inspired and exciting and serendipitous
liberal arts education the you know the
elite private uh liberal arts colleges
are most likely to fall first uh they
just you know they they are they are
less sclerotic um and more likely to be
taken over so you know the idea that the
entire system is anti-fragile no you
know just as brett said do we need do we
need higher ed yes we do but that
doesn't mean that the system we've got
now is what will persist but i also
think uh that nasim tuleb formulated
this concept so brilliantly that it
covers this right the academy is robust
it's very hard to displace it that's not
the same thing as anti-fragile right
basically it survives
by preventing challenge it does not grow
stronger with challenge and
i think that's one of the strongest
indicators that it has in its current
form
outlived its usefulness so maybe
sclerotic is robustness not
anti-fragility yeah an indicator of
robustness interesting
um one of the many uh neologisms you
describe in the book uh is the omega
principle and i want to read to you from
amazon um the omega principle is a
brilliant and engaging book that works
on many levels as a rousing
environmental manifesto of seafood and
the quest for long life is that what
you're talking about brett
no omega-3s no that's no no what is it
my friend tell me i don't know
okay so uh there's a book called the
omega principle you should know
you might get it you might hear from
their publisher now we do yes well we've
been playing with this concept for a
long time i'd be curious how old that
book is but in any case the idea
is that there is a fundamental question
if when you consider the evolution of
humans of our species
everybody understands since roughly 1976
when richard dawkins first introduced
the concept of cultural evolution in a
rigorous form
that we have culture and that it evolves
by rules that are similar to
genetic darwinism
what the field has never fully resolved
is what is the relationship between the
evolution of things at the cultural
layer and the evolution of things at the
genetic layer and dawkins himself argues
that the cultural layer is effectively
he calls it a new primeval soup right
effectively it is a
new evolution of stuff a place where
adaptation is uh happening
in a novel form
we argue that that cannot be right
right most creatures do not have culture
we are adapted to have a tremendous
amount of culture we make the argument
that human beings though not a blank
slate are the blanket slates that
selection has ever produced and that
there's a reason for that and that's
because being the blanket slates we end
up
doing the bidding of the genes far
better than we would if the genes hard
coded our behavior to a much higher
degree and so the omega principle
specifies the relationship between
epigenetic phenomena including culture
and the genes and the reason that we've
chosen omega is that as a greek letter
it evokes pi
pi specifies the exact relationship
between the diameter and the
circumference of a circle in the same
way that the omega principle specifies
the exact relationship
between epigenetic phenomena and the
genome and that relationship says
part one
epigenetic phenomena are more flexible
and more rapidly adapting but part two
they are obligated to the objectives of
the genes and once you make that once
you realize why that logically has to be
the case it makes evolutionary analysis
of human beings tractable because in
some sense you do not need to know
where the information is housed in order
to know what its objective is and this
is
crucially important in the case of
something like
let's say human language where the
capacity for language is clearly largely
generated by
genetic programming which creates a
brain of a certain uh that is hospitable
to language but it does not encode any
of the content of the particular
language you will learn right it's
housed in both places well how do you
factor that to figure out what what it's
supposed to do well the answer is it
doesn't matter what the admixture is in
terms of where the uh the hereditary
information is and how it is passed it's
for the same purpose either way
and i want to ask you a famous question
posed by erwin schrodinger but not
answered in his famous monograph what is
life
heather what is life and then i want to
add another monograph suggestion to you
brett uh what is culture along those
same physical lines perhaps so heather
what is life to you
what is life um
life is
self-organizing
and replicating with hereditary
information
that
i think self-correcting hereditary
the the hereditary information has to be
uh have error correction in there too i
have to think about that to make sure
that has to be part of life but i think
so
i actually like john lennon's
formulation somewhat better
life is what happens while you're making
other plans other plans
that would have been a simpler answer
yes that's right
so just just like you said the frogs
were self-organizing right yes that's
your point early on yeah all you were
doing was saying it's alive
it is alive um so now you want uh
culture culture okay well so this is the
part where i'm gonna tangle myself in
knots to avoid a tiny little exception
that i'm aware exists and is going to
force me not to say something very
simple and intuitive
but
culture is information
it is adaptive information pass outside
the
genome and the caveat it would be very
easy to say something like between
members of one species but that does not
have to be the case and in
the particular thing i'm worried about
has to do with the evolution of domestic
dogs where we have a very asymmetrical
relationship but there is a certain
amount of culture transmitted between
people and dogs and vice versa and
miraculously
the dogs have adapted to this in ways
that actually have physical hallmarks
right their ability to
exchange uh facial expressions right the
ability to control their faces in ways
that convey things
the amazing ability that they appear to
have to understand human language to
parse a large number of different words
uh all of these things suggest a
long-standing relationship in which
there is transmission of a kind but
anyway the general case for culture is
members of a species transmitting
information uh
outside of the genome
and
for human beings this is elaborated far
beyond even our closest relatives
because we have language which makes it
very efficient and opens the possibility
to what is uniquely the case in humans
the ability to transmit abstract ideas
between
individuals
now in our book we
divide two kinds of transmission of
information right what we call
consciousness
is about novel ideas that are parallel
processed between minds
right
what we call culture in the narrow sense
in the book are things that come from
ancestors who generated ideas
consciously and then those ideas get
driven into an efficient cultural
package that is passed on one generation
to the next and provides the substrate
with which
new members of the population are
brought into the fold and
trained in how to behave
brett i want to ask you another question
uh which has to do with
your famous research in telomeres i came
to ask the question i guess in the
following sense is there an analog of a
cultural telomeres are there analogs of
cultural telomeres
um
i'm going to have to think more deeply
about whether the telomeres themselves
are have an analog but there is a very
disturbing analog
to the process of senescence
that
we have
fairly long understood in evolutionary
biology right this is the process that
causes creatures like us to grow feeble
and inefficient
with age and we have known since roughly
1957 when george williams published his
excellent paper on the evolution of
senescence why it occurs why it evolves
the short answer being that your genome
isn't very big which means that the
genes in your genome tend to do more
than one thing and anytime a gene does
something good for you early in life
it will tend to be accumulated by
selection to be enhanced and passed on
even if it does something harmful to you
late in life the reason being many
individuals don't live long enough to
suffer the late life costs they get away
with it
and even for individuals who do live
long enough to suffer the late life cost
much of their reproduction is already
behind them and so the selective
disadvantage is small
okay so that's the reason we have a
genome full of genes that do two things
they give an early benefit at a late
life cost
the problem is that our civilization has
an analogous process to it it's almost
uh
almost beyond the level of analogy and
the basic point is when we invent a new
process that prov that produces some
benefit to us initially
it creates political and economic power
that makes it impossible to undo that
process if it turns out to have a much
later cost
and so in exactly the same way that the
body suffers all of those late life
costs after a number of years
civilization is built
in its current instantiation it is built
to senesce by virtue of us suffering all
of the costs for the economic activity
that produced profits
long ago and
if we are wise we will recognize the
degree to which that tells us where
we're headed and we will figure out how
to unplug that system and replace it
with something that doesn't have that
characteristic
very good yeah that kind of um
kind of presaged my final question to
the both of you which is is america
experiencing senescence uh and i do see
some yeah potential uh maybe over
torturing of that analogy but it does
seem in certain sense maybe heather you
can you you read a passage in the book
you talk about how to avoid it and you
talk about liberation anti-fragility and
uh the the propensity for for things
that aren't resilient or don't to resist
competition um maybe talk about that in
the final minutes and then i'm going to
turn to my patented final thrilling
three existential questions that i'm
going to ask both of you separately i've
never done this before but we'll use the
remaining minutes to do that is america
experiencing it and if so how can we
avoid it
it it does it does appear that way uh
and i guess what i was gonna ask you
brett as you were talking um
something i'm not sure we've ever even
talked about before
um is individuals experience senescence
senescence for the reasons that you lay
out and uh within a species we will we
can we can extend average lifespan but
we have very little chance of extending
maximum lifespan
but i don't think there's any reason to
think that a societal level that there
needs to be a maximum lifespan right and
so we talk in the book for instance
about the maya as an example of a
civilization uh that was so long-lived
and so um so long horizon thinking that
they actually have a unit of time the
baktun
which is over 400 years right so uh you
know and they had an enlightenment of
their own and they introduced the
concept of i mean they invented the
concept of zero and astronomy and
farming and written language and you
know they had so many of the things that
the european enlightenment in fact did
and
um
and yet they were failing before the
spaniards arrived right it was not it
was not the spaniards who took out the
maya although they certainly helped but
you know finished them off
so you know what
they lasted longer than america has
so even if there were a maximum lifespan
of civilizations we're certainly not
there and depending on how you count uh
china has certainly been going for
longer um although you might argue that
it's not the same it's not the same
civilization right um so
are we are we in the death rows
well it seems like it but maybe there
don't need to be death rows no i i think
i think
biology just has answered this question
and we've become so petty that we don't
understand that it's an answer
right and i think we need to look to the
biological solution to this and then
look for its analog in uh in the space
of civilization the way selection has
solved this problem
is that it has
treated
the body
as a temporary vessel
and in fact the very model that we
present in the book where we pass on a
tremendous amount of adapting evolving
information outside of the genome means
that you have children
they can pick up that fraction of what
you know that is still relevant right
they can discard the fraction that has
become outdated and they can advance the
ball
and that effectively
they are you but they are not exactly
you right they are an edit on you that
then keeps the process developing
through time they are the the
anti-fragile solution to the senescence
problem and in essence what we need to
do with respect to
the united states for example
is recognize that the founders
absolutely nailed it with respect to the
values
they
came up with a solution that was
actually in all likelihood much more
durable than they expected it to be but
it is now not surprising that people who
had never seen
a train or a chainsaw or an airplane or
the internet that they could you know
they couldn't have built a structure
that was going to be robust to this and
it is time for the 2.0 version something
that honors what they accomplished but
does not treat it with religious
devotion treats it as something that now
needs to have its offspring that's where
we need to go and i don't think it's a
sad thing i think it is a natural
transition and we should embrace it
actually if i can just um put a cap on
that uh we don't talk in the book about
species concepts and how it is that we
name species and how different types of
biologists think about what a species is
but one of the things that is certainly
true
is that um
as species change over time
absent branches coming off of them where
we can absolutely say yes that's
different now
we
we still tend to paleontologists still
give different names to those lineages
over time because they are
what is found is fossils and fossils get
different names
and
when if we think about political systems
the same way
america is changing
we have these unchanging founding
documents
uh but as it changes over time
just because it doesn't change names
doesn't mean that the thing itself can't
can't evolve interesting
okay uh i lied that i only had a couple
questions because i actually have my
audience questions but i'm gonna do
those in rapid fire if you guys will
play along um i will read a question you
could say yes or no or restrict it to a
one sentence question it could be both
of you guys either one of you guys
they're not directed at either of you
individually but as a group first from
lj do you have any thoughts on the
origin or purpose of music is it merely
a social tool meant to strengthen bonds
within or between groups or do you think
it's a bond that can be separated from
evolutionary history one sentence ago
music passes the adaptive test which we
present in the book with flying colors
it has no choice really but to be an
evolutionary adaptation
modern music has many purposes the
question is what is the original purpose
that caused the thing we call music to
evolve and it's a great question uh it
can't be answered in one sentence good
okay daltou asks explorer modes what are
they and how important are they for the
process of evolution
most explorers fail and we never hear
from them again absent explorers
we don't have
lineages branching and we have a very
low diversity and expansion into diverse
habitats on the planet
so i will add
evolution seeks
modes and forms
that
function that get genes into the future
it is much less efficient to search all
of the possible design space for modes
that work than to limit one search to
things that are likely to be functional
selection over time will develop
mechanisms that reduce the search space
those are the explorer modes
the heuristics of space yeah
and then combined with survivorship bias
that we tend only to hear from the ones
that survived uh results in some
quite prejudicial uh outcomes supposedly
okay the next question comes from blair
james ryan he has a question similar to
the one i wanted to ask your thoughts on
how the modern diet and processed foods
like seed oils and sugars have created
obesity and diabetes
heart disease and dementia and i wasn't
familiar with dementia but
maybe
one of you can take that and then i have
a follow-up question about allergies
uh absolutely they have and there is
increasing evidence uh for their role in
dementia as well including some of i
can't remember the name of a few of the
molecules involved in shelf stability
that absolutely are involved in things
like alzheimer's and parkinson's
i had a question about uh allergies um
so i'm only allergic to one thing which
is not uh which is stopping eating i get
i break out when i stop eating uh but uh
i never remember you know gluten-free
and peanut allergies when i was a wee
lad 40 50 years ago uh what do you guys
make of this is this a byproduct is it
why are we hitting this you know hockey
stick moment with where it seems to be
so prevalent you can hardly go to a
restaurant which isn't like all these
symbols and they're not like kosher
symbols yeah what does it make of the
exponential increase of these of these
uh
allergies well i think there are two
things that are likely in play
one of them
allergies are typically mediated by the
ige system and the ige system is a
system that would have been busy with
things like parasitic worms in a past
environment things that we've been very
effective at eliminating which is a good
thing it has immunoglobulin e yep it's a
class of of antibody
and in any case there is substantial
evidence that suggests that this system
left idle targets things that it
shouldn't right it won't target pollen
grains or whatever else but then there's
also hold on which is very much the
argument we make with regard to the
appendix in the book as well right
another biological fence right yeah so
the other thing is that there is there
are various factors that are causing the
immune system to either be overactive or
to see things that it is not supposed to
for example
most of the immune system is not
supposed to see the contents of your gut
and the reason that's not supposed to
see the contents of your gut is that
when you are very early in development
the system looks at every molecule that
you yourself make
and it eliminates the subset of cells
that react to it and what that produces
after you're past the stage of
development is a very elegant system
that
sees every invader but does not see you
and this system can screw up
right if this system sees things it
shouldn't it can react to things that
are a normal part of life like foods
that you eat and it can react to them as
if they are potentially pathogenic it
can also react to your own cells
creating an autoimmunity and so
allergies to things that we eat
appear to be the result of a mistake by
the self non-self recognition system
that causes the equivalent of an
autoimmune disorder not to you but to
your food right
why
are the contents of our gut being seen
by the immune system and therefore
recorded as likely pathogenic that is an
open question there are many possible
answers but i think we need to be
looking in this uh this realm and we
need to say well it may be too late for
some of us i have a severe wheat allergy
there's nothing i'm likely to be able to
do about that but what we can do is we
can figure out what causes this and then
prevent young people from encountering
whatever those influences are so that
they don't develop these in out of these
allergies in in future generations
uh next question comes from
jm
uh what types of adaptations would you
expect in populations that are
chronically vitamin d deficient
well
um
i feel like we know the answer to this
and i just i'm not remembering
it's it's it's rickets it's weak bones
it's short stature it's deformed bones
that's the question there's more than
that there's there's intellectual stuff
as well and i can't remember exactly
what but the question was what
adaptations do you expect to see yeah
so i think
the answer is
um because of the nature of trade-offs
and that there are certain to be
trade-offs involved in
um the production of vitamin d what you
would expect to see
is things that increase the productivity
of vitamin d
so vitamin d is produced by the skin in
response to sunlight
the
ability to produce vitamin d will exist
in a trade-off relationship with other
things so for example
you might expect to see a reduction in
melanin
in populations and that reduction in
melanin is not going to be free it comes
with the cost like the more likely to
produce tumors but i would expect to see
a shift in the trade-off between the
production of vitamin d and resistance
to other things where the body accepts
more vulnerability in some other regard
in order to reduce the cost of
insufficient vitamin d maybe similarly
paler hair and thinner hair right and
one other thing is i would also expect
that what we've so far talked about are
things that are likely to be wholly
transmitted in the genome but you would
also expect behavioral compensations
right so you might imagine that the
traditions of people who are chronically
low in vitamin d might involve
pursuing sunlight
when it is available in spite of the
cost to
retention of heat for example you might
expect
traditions to include things in the diet
which contain vitamin d we in fact know
this to be the case
and so anyway basically the point is you
would expect selection to find every
alteration of belief
behavior structure
that will cause an increase in the
production of vitamin d or a
preservation in vitamin d that's already
been produced and would otherwise be
destroyed you would expect selection to
find all those things over time and
accumulate them
uh okay the last one of these well one
uh so someone named j sarge 499.
that was actually the name i was going
to choose for my first kid what is the
future of biological inquiry are there
still major gains to be made in terms of
evolutionary theory do you see things
taking a major molecular chemical turn
there are massive advances yet to be
made and
largely unfortunately we've stalled out
in part due to the
the financial model of the modern
university which encourages very
expensive research over theoretical
research which tends to be far cheaper i
also think that there's a cultural bias
you know we're very early in the study
of biology and it's a very complex topic
it is the most complex topic really and
so we should expect ourselves to still
be
fumbling around with some basics but the
degree to which
biologists you know if you look at the
bio 101 textbook
it reads just as encyclopedically as the
chemistry 101 textbook right
and that's an indication that something
has gone wrong and if you listen into
the you know the
the intro series to biology you don't
hear a lot of here are 47 things we
don't know the answer to yet they don't
include the black boxes just with like
gloss
which is crazy because if you want to
train the mind that's the place to do it
let's hang out inside this box for a
while and see if we can figure our way
out yep all right
uh next question is about a spin 14
generalization of uh unification of
quantum mechanics and relativity
that's for heather
um no that's the wrong weinstein brother
here sorry about that sean g
uh next last question i'll take from the
audience uh this guy has a lot he wants
you guys to have noam chomsky on past
guest on the into the impossible podcast
because he claims and
we're making finger puppets of you guys
but he claims that chomsky
finds convincing this communication is
not even a secondary function of
language uh he goes on to other
questions but he asks five other
questions i'm gonna ask just one simple
one heather do peacocks use their sons
as decoys to shield their daughters
as decoys to shield their daughters
that's his question
no
uh i'm not sure i even understand the
framing do you know do you know what is
being yeah i kind of i kind of get it
but um do you want to translate it for
me and i'll just
uh it's not the right
term but the idea
the idea is if you were to um if you
were to go straight handicap right as a
hobby handicap principle um
then the point is
from the point of view of a male
offspring that puts on this tale to
demonstrate he could deal with the
handicap yes he demonstrates awesome
genes because he's got the handicap but
he also suffers from the handicap and so
in order for that to be the opposite
then well in order to seems like the
opposite of what is true for it to pay
the benefit to females who get the
benefit of the good genes but don't pay
the cost of the tail has to be
effectively
twice more than twice in order to
compensate for the loss of their son so
it's not really decoy but are they
sacrificing their sons yes to enhance
their daughters and the answer is
no
well the answer is no but it will not be
obvious why the answer is no i'm very
much looking forward to presenting that
analysis at some point in the future if
you guys have a few more minutes i know
you have a pretty hard break coming up
but uh
i found very interesting and of course
my audience will be expect nothing less
than your thoughts on aliens and you
make a statement in the book i forget
which one of you reads it but that
aliens will sleep when we encounter when
we encounter alien not if we encount but
when we they will be um you know kind of
nocturnal diurnal entities as well as we
what basis do you make that on uh first
of all heather do you believe in the
existence of intelligent
extraterrestrial beings and brett if you
think so why do you believe that they
will have diurnal and nocturnal
behaviors like we do
yes and i really hope that we find them
and it's it'll be a very good thing if
they do
also sleep because then if they come by
while we're asleep they'll know to wait
until we're
we're up because we wouldn't want to
miss them right that's right no that's
right that would be embarrassing yeah
and maybe they can help me sleep train
one of my kids that would be nice right
if you want to know why yes yeah well
the argument is like this
in order for creatures to be
sophisticated enough to engage in this
kind of travel there are certain things
that are very likely to be true of the
planet that they evolved on
a day and night is a highly likely
phenomenon should they have a day and
night it is likely that just as the
creatures of earth are biased towards
activity in one or the other period
because there are trade-offs in the
building of things like eyes for example
so if you have a really great diurnal
eye it tends not to collect enough light
for night and if you have a really great
amplifying uh eye then it tends to not
be so acute during the day and so those
things will cause a highly intelligent
creature to have faced a period of time
over which it was not highly productive
and
simple dormancy is a
huge opportunity cost because if you've
got the kind of computer that can do
really careful thinking and it's offline
because you can't be productive because
your eyes aren't adapted to either day
or night that
the selection will inevitably discover
that it can borrow that apparatus and so
its sleep is liable to have some of the
characteristics of ours including
possibly things like dreaming let me
just say that you alighted what may be
the most interesting uh part but maybe
the most obvious to an astronomically
interested audience which is that the
intelligent aliens that land here and
wonder and don't wonder why we sleep are
likely to have day and night because the
tidally locked planet is unlikely to
have allowed for the evolution of such
complex life that's right and that
actually comes to mind last question
which has to do with uh the potential
danger then of a future
space force colony on the moon which uh
does not is tidally locked to the earth
and therefore doesn't experience diurnal
uh fast forward you know many thousands
of years in the future um you know i
often say like we live in an amazing age
you talk about the campfire etc my
grandmother guys i mean she grew up with
the horse and buggy she grew up you know
in the shtetls of of eastern poland and
and lived to see men walking on tick
tock but i want to ask you if
if we do go to the moon
will there be will there be um detriment
you know will it be kind of too popular
two cultures that will arrive you know
those that kind of had the
whatever benefit perhaps of growing up
in a diurnal non-totally locked system
or whether it be you know detrimental to
people living on on the moon it will
have anatomical and physiological
effects it will uh and we don't know
what all of them are just as as much as
we tried to figure out before the space
race was a thing uh what all of the
effects would be of those very short
periods um in in you know in in spaces
without gravity for instance would have
we still could not begin to actually
fully understand it
but wait i'm a little bit lost here
because if we put a colony on the moon
it will have day and night they'll be
two weeks long two weeks long right
but
i mean biotically speaking the moon is
not a high productivity environment can
we just all agree on that no
no the objectives is zero productivity
that's right so
you know it's all going to come
by amazon or something right it's going
to be shipped there and therefore the
idea of a productive period during the
day is going to be off the table right
you're going to be productive we're
going to
create
a day and night cycle that is however
long is optimal for humans likely
something like 24 hours although when we
put people in caves it doesn't turn out
to be 24 hours but it doesn't matter 25
um but nonetheless we'll just build an
artificial environment i mean i'm not
advocating for hanging out in the moon
that doesn't sound like a ton of fun to
me but right but i mean i think i mean i
think maybe part of what the question
that you're asking
ends up getting at is one of the one of
the big themes of the book we haven't
really talked about is a tendency
towards reductionism in modern science
and you know imagine that the thing that
you can measure that the metric that
you've got in hand is the most important
thing about the system and so in order
to survive in a colony on the moon we
will figure out those basic things you
know people are not going to find
themselves as fixating because we got
that thing wrong
but we will not have gotten to a lot of
the emergent necessary truths that
humans will need in order to live like
we do on this planet and lucky for elon
as he says he wants to die on mars as
lord martin reece past guest on the show
said yes but let's hope he doesn't die
on impact uh mars has a 20 almost
24-hour cycle so that would a diurnal
nocturnal cycle okay guys i'm going to
ask you to do something i've never done
before if you'll indulge me which is one
of you guys is gonna answer my thrilling
three existential questions about advice
to your former here are the three
questions and i'd like you to unplug
your headphones one of you at a time so
i can have the other one be uh ignorant
of the other's answer and i'd love to
hear you guys answer independently if
that's okay okay but the problem is
whoever takes off their headphone is
going to hear the answer to the question
so it's not a i mean you want one of us
to leave or maybe you could leave yeah
maybe one of you could leave or put on
some heavy metal music
uh who's leaving no you go first i mean
i'm gonna speak first you gotta go do
the leaving and uh okay i'll see you
shortly okay good thanks guys it never
happened before all right and into the
impossible podcast okay heather these
are basically either far future
questions or far past questions i like
to ask all my guests to kind of bring
out the humanity and all of my guests uh
not that you guys need any but um but
they involve around kind of questions of
legacy which is prominent in this book i
want to ask you first what you'd put in
your ethical will which is a concept
from judaism called the zava ah
it's a type of wisdom or value system
that you most would like to articulate
to near-term generations as their
inheritance sort of a
a will for your ideological errors not
necessarily your only or biological
errors
so a you know a set of instructions or
wisdom or compilation of value system
that you live by sort of you know
relatively brief yeah i i guess
this is going to sound like it's
cheating but i think uh i think it's
this book that we just wrote and um if i
have to encapsulate it more
it's perhaps the epilogue
which is the eight
eight things eight principles that we
say during the eight nights of hanukkah
and i won't be able to
to say them off the top of my head here
do it anyway we want the audience to buy
the book yeah
great and the next one goes a little bit
farther into the future now a billion
years into the future and you've
probably seen the movie 2001 a space
odyssey based on arthur c clark where i
am the associate co-director of the
arthur c clark center for human
imagination
yeah in the opening scenes uh there are
these uh primates in the savannah of
africa and they come upon one of these
ominous monoliths and i want to ask you
we don't know what they're for they
could be a time capsule to be discovered
by humans or some other civilization you
know be tokening our existence
so i want to ask you what would you put
on
your monolith something destined to last
billions of years
it has some similarity to the famous
question that richard feynman asked you
know what scientific knowledge in his
case would you uh encapsulates the most
knowledge in in his field of physics in
this fewest words so i want to ask you
what kind of information or statement
about things that you've learned in your
life would you most want to put on a
monolith a time capsule to be token our
great achievements as a human species
i guess it depends on whether or not
these are our descendants
undisturbed and therefore they are
preceding a pace from here or if if life
has has disappeared and this is a new
evolution
um you know descent with modification
is the simplest definition of evolution
and
it
it is the encapsulation of what explains
what we are so if i have to go very very
simple i think i would do that descent
with modification
great and the last question of my
thrilling three final questions uh has
to do with going back in time not a
billion years but just uh 20 30 years i
want to ask you uh sir arthur c clarke
he had many laws one of which is in
every expert there's an equal and
opposite expert he said any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic and i actually have his voice
reading that phrase when i open every
podcast but heather one of his law his
questions is actually how i got the name
for this podcast and he said the only
way
of discovering the limits of the
possible is to go beyond them into the
impossible so that's the name of this uh
podcast but i want to ask you heather uh
what thing about life mystified you as a
20 year old a 30 year old what advice
would you give to that former self to
give you the courage to do as you've
done to go into the impossible
well there's
it's a little earlier but there's a way
in which you know i like all teenagers i
think was searching for meaning and uh
searching not just for you know what my
place was in the world but really
explicitly searching for
what what was this all about
and uh you know again this this will
seem single note but to me it's you know
it's it's all explanatory except for
really your domain and the domain of the
very very tiny and abiotic so you know
quarks and rocks and quasars are off the
table but pretty much everything else is
evolutionary so
you know i was experimenting with
buddhism and other religious traditions
and actually brett handed me a book by
dawkins um when i was you know 19 or 20
and said i think you will find things
herein that you will find explanatory
and uh it certainly wasn't complete but
it revealed to me a way of framing the
world
uh that i i keep with me to this day and
also what it part of what it promises is
that we will never know everything that
you know of course the act of science is
to try to discover what's true and we
are aiming to get to an ever more
accurate refinement of our understanding
of reality but we're not going to get
there in our lifetimes and that's part
of what is so marvelous about it
wonderful well if you would indulge me
and
go and get your
other half
hold on just a second
okay brett i i asked your lovely wife
heather these three questions that i've
asked your brother
um and uh all of my did they get the
answers right
there's going to be homework at the end
of this brett you know that always okay
all right so these are existential
questions two of which will go deep into
the future your own personal future when
you spring forth this mortal coil at the
biblical age of 120 or more perhaps you
can extend your life and your telomeres
uh but i want to ask you first what
you'd put in your zaba ah your ethical
will
that is what wisdom or values would you
like to you know inculcate or articulate
to future generations of biological but
mostly your ideological errors that come
after you
yeah
i mean
i think the answer here is actually
simple
and it's
very biological but i believe that
if one extrapolates from
from what i'm about to say that one
recovers all of the important
moral and ethical stuff
the idea is
we are obligated
to try to provide
the
experience of a liberated
human existence
as liberated as possible to as many
people
as we can that the the
marvelousness of being a human being is
so special and unique
that given that what we do affects how
many people will get to experience it we
have an obligation to behave in a way
that maximizes that number and the
reason that i think
that the all the proper
moral and ethical stuff that needs to
flows from extrapolating from that
principle
is that a
it forces you to behave in ways that are
maximally sustainable
those maximally sustainable ways
therefore
uh involve the discovery of the various
steady states we will need and in order
for the human life that we deliver to
those in the future
for it to be truly liberating we will
have to have addressed
their many concerns that is to say to be
meaningfully liberated rather than just
nominally liberated you have to have
your mundane concerns
addressed so we would end up
i think
if we really worked on this puzzle we
would end up
protecting people
from things like bad luck we would end
up connecting them
together in ways that caused flourishing
when people discovered
insights or created
enhancements to human well-being
they would end up needing to
suffer some sort of a penalty when they
externalized harm onto others and i
think that this would cascade all the
way through
the social architecture
such that even
to interpersonal relationships it would
cause the right values uh to be enhanced
very good although slightly awkward
because heather just extolled your
virtues for about five minutes straight
and uh now i can say you didn't
reciprocate
okay next up no she didn't do that no
okay
next we're going to go deep into the
future and you probably are undoubtedly
familiar with arthur c clarke's famous
book the sentinel which led to a space
odyssey in which there are these
monoliths that the
prehistoric creatures in africa these
hominid like figures encounter and they
hit it with a bone and later it appears
on the moon and clark doesn't really
reveal what these things are and of
course i am the
associate co-director of the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination here
at uc san diego so it's near and dear to
my heart i want to ask you if these are
thought of as time capsules as sort of
monoliths that are meant to encapsulate
or be token things that humanity has
learned or achieved what would you put
on your monolith and it's sort of
similar to feynman's cataclysm question
in which he said if in some cataclysm
all of human knowledge were destroyed
and only one sentence passed on to the
next generation of creatures what
statement contains the most information
in the fewest words i want to ask you in
your field he put forth the atomic
hypothesis
what do you think would encapsulate the
most knowledge that we've acquired in
the fewest most condensed compressed
form of a statement on a
billion-year-lasting time capsule
wow
um
that is so i'm stuck here i i must say
uh 2001 is one of my favorite stories
and i've done a lot of thinking about
the monoliths but i've never thought
about them as time capsules at all
um
they seem to me more like triggers but
okay so if you had
if you had to preserve
one concept
you know what it would be
it's actually
it's in our book um
it's a figure
and the figure is stacked diminishing
returns curves
because
every complex system in which there is
an
objective will
show a pattern of diminishing returns
and the key to success at whatever the
objective might be
is knowing when you've hit the
inflection point and would be foolish to
keep investing in the same way and what
you need to do is seek the next
um
face the next bargain phase of the next
curve in the stack
and if people
understood this i believe you know i
think it's right up there potentially
wow i shouldn't say such a thing um it
is a dim shadow of
yin yang right which i find a very
compelling concept the idea of a
symmetry that is about compatibleness
rather than sameness
right
and
i believe if if one understands the
implications of the stacked diminishing
returns curves one is in a better
position
to
maximize whatever is
sought
very good okay now we're going to go
back in time not billions of years not
millions of years in the future we're
going to go backwards in time
and quote sir arthur c clarke his famous
third law
which states the only way of discovering
the limits of the possible is to venture
a little way past them into the
impossible and that's the origin of the
name of my podcast i want to ask you
brett what mysterious aspect of life
perplexed you as a as a 20 year old 30
year old even um but that what advice
would you give to that young man to give
him the courage to do as you've done to
go into the impossible
well i'm not sure exactly how to answer
the question i certainly believe in this
principle and i have advocated
that
while
arrogance is a bad thing we can all
agree that if one has to air in one
direction or the other it's far better
than humbleness because
humbleness if you feel obligated to
to view yourself as
less capable
then you will fall short of what you
might be able to achieve whereas if you
believe beyond your actual capabilities
that you might be capable of something
you'll at least find out what you can do
and you won't leave anything on the
table so i believe in the principle that
you have to go beyond in order to figure
out
what is uh what is within range
you know i had the telomere
experience
was transformative it was very early for
me it was you know as a young graduate
student
and the experience of having
correctly predicted
that
wild mice would have short telomeres
even though the literature said many
many times over that mice have long
telomeres that even in some places said
rodents have long telomeres
[Music]
discovering that i had been correct
about that that i had done the logic
well enough that it could predict a
result in a laboratory
was very freeing because
after that point
it didn't really matter if people
you know
doubted my capability
i knew that at least once i had
succeeded in that and i never had to
worry too much that you know i was
fooling myself or something along those
lines so i would i would
i would advise people in fact i have
advised my own students
to seek
an experience that frees you in that way
right to
to
set objectives for yourself
scientifically and otherwise
that even if it takes many such attempts
to find something in which you discover
the limits of what you can do that it at
least allows you to to tune out the
doubters because you know they can't
possibly be right
and you need that confidence in order to
uh to
succeed especially in a very cutthroat
field like academia i always call it the
academic hunger games and conversations
past and present with your
elder brother
i want to thank you so much for coming
on the into the impossible podcast uh
for having your courage uh to produce
this work there are about 50 other
questions i could have asked but time
does not permit me nor does discretion
do so as well but i want to uh recommend
everybody please do pick up a copy of a
hunter-gatherer's guide to the 21st
century i'm looking forward to the bonus
uh guide that comes with a poisonous
tree frog
that would be a delight
and i just want to thank you for sharing
your honesty your courage uh your candor
with myself and my audience and i hope
we can meet up again someday it has been
a terrific pleasure thank you this was
great thanks brian thank you guys
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
if you enjoyed this episode with heather
heing and brett weinstein you may not
like this episode with dr eric topal
who
spoke with me
earlier this summer about the delta
variant and some of the controversial
solutions that have been proposed to
combat it
click here for my other interviews that
you might like